you know the final countdown to the
Grammys is on CBS it's underway with
music's biggest night now just two days
away and Counting singer Alicia Keys who
will host the awards show rolled out the
red carpet in Los Angeles yesterday
she's ready firstly kicking off the
celebration
Entertainment Tonight chose Kevin
Frazier's at Staples Center in LA where
the 61st Grammy Awards will take place
Kevin good morning I feel like it's
going to be ladies night you know it's
funny you say that Gail because that's
what people are saying it will be ladies
night you know the stage is already set
and rehearsals are underway but a lot of
people believe that ladies will win big
let me show you where some of the
biggest stars in the music universe will
sit and let's start with this power trio
how about Lady gaga Jennifer Lopez
followed by a woman who could win big
cardi beat and interesting that she will
be sitting next to her estranged husband
off set maybe they're working things out
now cardi is one of two women who are
nominated in two of the big categories
record of the year and album of the year
she's nominated along with Brandi
Carlile now the Academy faced a little
criticism over the lack of female
representation last year but it won't
just be women who are nominated they
will also be honored the incomparable
Diana Ross will be sitting right here
will be part of the Motown tribute and
they also expect that her landmark
career will be celebrated Berry Gordy is
gonna sit right there and then there
will be the tribute to Dolly Parton now
Little Big Town Maren Morris Kacey
Musgraves
and Katy Perry will be a part of that
big question is will her goddaughter
Miley Cyrus be a part of this
Miley sitting right next to Dolly and
I'm figuring that Liam Hemsworth will be
right here in the hot seat in between
the two of them now ariana grande was
expected to perform but she got into a
public spat with producers she says she
offered three songs didn't feel
supported she is out but it's okay
because you know who zingale the person
you mentioned Alicia Keys and she says
that the show will be bigger
better this year and next hour we will
sit down with Alicia Keys I'll get ready
for ladies night from the holes too we
think will win Gail I think the ladies
will rule the evening I'm getting
excited
we decide I'm excited too I can't wait
for Sunday night gonna stay up late on a
school night thanks a lot and don't
forget you got the Gracie's yeah
you can watch the Grammys is Sunday at
8:00 7:00 central right here on where no
road on CBS there you go